lexus has launched a compact class
hybrid a revised ct200h
it offers individuality luxury
technology and low fuel consumption
lexus says the 100 kilowatt engine burns
3.8 liters of super per 100 kilometers
but that figure can vary greatly
depending on the stretch driven
our card tester montesquiret says the
hybrid ct200h's advantages are
especially apparent in the city and at
low speeds
that's when it shifts to the electric
engine using no gasoline at all but if
you drive on a rural road at a faster
speed then fuel consumption rises so
that you now have an average rate of 6.1
per 100 kilometers
that's still pretty low for a gasoline
engine but there are diesel models in
this segment that undercut it
so much for the engine in the interior
the driver faces an array of technology
mata says operating the infotainment
system with this joysticks takes some
getting used to but once you're
accustomed to it it works quite well the
car also has voice recognition and we'll
try that out now
the gps system's voice says the driver
should name an abbreviation menu after
the tone and that he can get assistance
by seeing help
says enter a destination
the gps repeats the command
and then asks for the name of a city it
explains at length how you can alter the
country name and begin a new search
breaks off the conversation he doesn't
have the patience for the system's
long-windedness though he concedes it
may be helpful for someone not used to
talking with a machine about operations
he doesn't understand
this way he'll learn all his options
the interior of the lexus is luxurious
the finest materials comfortable seats
and an instrument cluster that changes
its gauges to fit the driving mode
but the central console is initially
confusing
once again things take getting used to
says matas everything has been kept
relatively simple but all the technology
means lots of buttons matas thinks the
control knobs for the seat heating are a
bit odd
he's never seen them in another car
but once you accustom yourself to them
as with the infotainment system they're
okay
by the infotainment system done
the lexus differs not only internally
but externally from other european car
makers compact offerings lexus designed
the ct200h specifically for the european
market
mata says the ct-200h is very attractive
for those who love technology but the
compact segment is very competitive in
europe and how many people are this
fascinated with technology
high quality and workmanship is also a
criterion and many of lexus's european
competitors are just as good or even
better and so our car tester wonders
whether the ct-200h will prevail on the
market over the long haul
the ct-200h's high starting price of 27
600 euros will make it hard for lexus to
grab market shares from vw golf and the
others in this class but for a compact
hybrid the price is decent and the
selection of compact hybrids is still
very limited in europe someone looking
for one could soon find himself getting
into the lexus